situation actuelle si la compétition
économique reste le nerf de la guerre
pour les entreprises américaines
l'administration un ghana décidé voilà
plusieurs mois d'investir massivement
dans un nouveau domaine de la
technologie militaire une technologie
dont les retombées sur le plan
économique sont évidemment considérable
ce nouveau domaine est celui de l'espace
qui devient le show ouvert de la
concurrence entre les grandes puissances
si américains soviétiques continue à
genève de négocier le sort de l'armement
nucléaire dans l'espace tout est ternie
patrick esther la bataille de l'espace
et commencer à gauche
la navette américaine à droite le soyouz
soviétique
plus question de démonstration pour la
gloire comme c'était le cas avec la
course à la lune les années 60 ce bien
de stratégie militaire qu'il s'agit
maintenant la navette est financé en
grande partie par les militaires n'est
qu'un tag auj
bientôt elle sera tiré depuis un nouveau
pack cuir sur une base militaire à
l'abri des regards indiscrets côté urss
letra spatiale est le plus gros
satellite actuellement en orbite
il occupe en permanence la banlieue
reste 23 mars 83 ronald reagan réveille
la méfiance du peuple américain à
l'égard de l'urss s'en montrant ses
photos pour le président des états unis
tous les clichés réalisés par les
satellites démontre le suréquipement de
moscou en missiles nucléaires
en réalité les photos des satellites
restent toujours secrètes et le tai chi
montré à la presse ou été pris par un
avion espion le sr-71 pour les besoins
du discours politique
les photos des femmes satellites espions
big bird sont beaucoup plus précises
on y distingue les détails gros comme
une balle de tennis
dans son appel ronald reagan engagé les
usa à construire des engins capables de
neutraliser depuis l'espace les missiles
nucléaires intercontinentaux soviétique
cinq mois plus tard seulement
un avion c 130 5 d'école d'une base
tenue secrète à son bord un rayon laser
à haute énergie cinq fois de suite le
faisceau va abattre en un millième de
seconde
sami s'il évolue loin à 3500 km
compte tenu du poids limité de ce laser
est sa miniaturisation
rien n'empêche plus maintenant les
américains de placer en orbite une arme
de ce type
côté soviétique on n'est pas en reste il
y a deux ans déjà un satellite avait été
téléguidée pour détruire un autre engin
évoluant dans l'espace
et c'est à la chaîne que ces argents
cosmiques sont fabriqués
sur les 2500 satellite tirés depuis le
premier spoutnik 1500 sont des cosmos
soviétique
les deux tiers à vocation militaire
l'airé cesse de plus a entrepris la
fabrication d'une fusée dont on dit
qu'elle sera la plus puissante jamais
construite
probablement pour lancer une énorme
station orbitale une petite navette de
quatre mètres d'envergure a elle aussi
déjà volé avant la fin des années 80 les
américains auront probablement placer
une station en orbite
bardé de radars de moyens sophistiqués
de détection et de communication mais
aussi de laser
sans atteindre cette technologie les
chinois ont rejoint depuis peu le club
des pays utilisant militairement
l'espace en lançant cinq satellites
espions
enfin même si la fusée ariane a été
construite par l'europe uniquement à des
fins commerciales et civiles
cela n'empêche pas la france de caresser
pour 85
le projet d'un satellite militaire de
reconnaissance
aujourd'hui russes et américains savent
à battre depuis le sol des avions avec
des faisceaux de particules
demain c'est pinceau de lumière seront
capables de traverser les couches de
l'atmosphère déjà et soviétiques ont
réussi à neutraliser un satellite
américain jugés trop curieux en la
doublant alors dans les décennies à
venir
la maîtrise de l'espace la possession
d'armes sophistiquées sera bel et bien
une réalité et une nécessité stratégique
revenons sur terre avec ce dernier
incident diplomatique qui fait grand
bruit à washington